okay what were you guys thoughts like
immediate reaction was crazy on the
internet initially arkansas said it was
fake you dropped it did you think i
thought it was fake i thought it was
fake i don't anymore but initially i was
like there's no way that's real okay and
then i was watching with duchar and my
wife and they're like no chris's energy
shifts way too hard there's a moment i
don't know if y'all notice when chris is
about to clap back not not like fight
him but he goes keep your wife's will
goes keep your wife's name i don't know
keep my wife's name out of your mouth
and chris goes
yeah he was about to unload he needed to
yeah he did he needed to and he we would
have been completely fine if he went
crazy bleep him out whatever yeah you
got slapped on tv yeah 100 like not on
tv the tv
literally the four losers the super bowl
the theater nerd super virgin super bowl
the virgin super bowl he got slapped
yeah and
it's so [ __ ] crazy because the
initial reaction was like yo chris is
[ __ ] blah blah i don't think chris is
[ __ ] for not hitting will back i think
he's supposed to be because he was
worried about his career
yeah i thought he was worried about his
career but i also think like if he acts
crazy if he acts professional in that
moment all the execs and everything are
oh my god thank you so much for doing
that and you acted like a man will
you i don't know if we can trust this
person he's got issues mental health is
that the other and then chris is the
ultimate professional you know what i'm
saying yeah but it didn't work out like
that what do you mean we're not looking
at them like that the people are like
not us i'm saying the decision makers in
hollywood like he didn't hit him back so
he could be in zootopia four
right he's like i need to be doing
voiceover work i need to do all that
[ __ ] which is sad it's that's the sad
thing yeah that's the sodium that's his
career son antonio brown
is not beholden to no one yeah antonio
brown that's a horrible example
exactly
in that situation go go oh i gotta make
sure that i keep my composure and i
don't you know say curse out the the
coach i don't do any of that kind of
[ __ ] antonio brown said [ __ ] it took off
the jersey i do whatever i want i'm not
beholden to the nfl now i'm not saying
you should be antonio brown but he's
free
that [ __ ] is free to act whoever
he wants and he doesn't do what the nfl
wants he doesn't do what the coach wants
you know what buccaneers wants he does
what antonio brown [ __ ] wants lloyd
mayweather
sure he don't have no sponsors he's not
he didn't have to worry about people
pulling out whatever yeah he's i'm going
to sell my next fight on my own make 100
million dollars and i could tell me [ __ ]
better example [ __ ] because chris rock
can't do movies but he could do stand up
yes he literally his new toy is called
ego death antonio brown
getting slapped at the oscars and not
doing nothing you can't have an ego
about that bro
and he can't even come back and make
jokes about will yes he can yes he can
there's two types of black people
there's black people and then there's
will smith
every time black people want to have a
good time will smith come and [ __ ] it up
that's good
yo well smith always wants some credit
for some [ __ ] you're supposed to do
i protect my family you're supposed to
your dumb [ __ ]
be my full
i hate will smith
the media you think when i'm at the
oscars i'm looking in the audience for
the media no i'm looking for will smith
that's gonna be so fired okay fine